so right what are we going to talk about
today then well we're going to talk
about packages and libraries and and and
I'm really kind of understanding what we
really mean by this stuff for those that
don't know a packaging go is a basically
a folder full of go files
hopefully with test files too they can
be imported into other projects we're
not talking about commands you know
we're talking about things that you
import to help you use help do something
solve some of the problem for you that
hopefully somebody else has written for
you yeah but you you also hopefully
open-source these as well and that's
kind of part of the whole kind of go
ethos since it's an open source project
itself it's great to to you know
contribute if you can and and and I'm
gonna hopefully cover some some
practices and some things that we can we
can do to write these beautiful packages
that everyone's going to want to use so
what do I really mean then what is a
beautiful package well yes it's quite
tough to define it in fact they're
elegant and simple
you have a very familiar feeling might
be obvious you know when you look at it
when you just glance at the API it's it
should be quite obvious what it's going
to do you you hopefully already know how
to use it just by kind of looking at it
you know we can just be self-similar as
a go community and if we do that it
gives us a kind of head start when we
jump into actually working on these and
there are packages that I look forward
to using and some that I don't and
therefore I think there's we can say
that packages are better than others in
some ways and we can look at why that is
and and talk about it and that's what
I'm gonna do not going to like show
terrible packages or anything don't
worry so when you come to write a
package then motivation is is one of the
one of the things to think about from
the beginning I think don't write
packages for the sake of it it's very
tempting and sometimes we want to do it
for fun
and do if you want to do it for fun do
it but but really the the the best
packages are ones where you solve your
own problems solving something you need
and you're not kind of guessing you're
not doing something assuming this is
someone's gonna have this problem so I'm
gonna preempt it it's tough to get that
right and you know it's more difficult
so and if you have a big project and you
think okay here's a little piece of our
thing that we need but the open-source
community probably gonna appreciate it
to then keep internal to start without
say really get it battle-tested when
you're happy with it you'll learn so
much just by doing that the it's going
to be a better package once it's once
it's ready to go and you know this the
the web 2.0 movement gave us these
gorgeous websites that are very easy to
use and you know the informations at the
top that you need and you can easily
find other bits of information by
drilling down and all this this was this
whole kind of web 2.0 movement and it's
kind of started with people thinking
about user centered design things like
this so they started to build personas a
bit like as Steve was talking about in
the keynote starting to think about
users really quite obsessively and not
just what they're trying to do but how
they're feeling about using the software
and and and you know what their goals
are and what their their motivations are
and you know packages in go and really
any language they are they have an API
you know they have an interface and
although we think of them as running in
production at scale by you know in its
machines calling calling them well
really they're not they're they are used
by humans initially right that says
where the humans I'm talking about so
that this user centered design applies
directly to write in packages I think so
we should think about the same way so
think about who's using the package what
are they trying to do with
and in what context are they using it is
it is it something that's foundational
to a project so you're going to spend a
lot of time with it in the beginning and
then you won't touch it
is it something they're just using
testing or debugging is it a package
that they're gonna call throughout the
code it's gonna be scattered everywhere
you know those thinking about that and
the use and where your package is gonna
be but that I think is is pretty vital
when it comes to your design too far
I was in Spitalfields market once and
one of the market vendor guys said to me
became really close a bit too close and
said I like specific things which is the
best sentence I've ever heard and told
me nothing about him but yeah it likes
specific things which is fine so let's
get into some specific things about
packages smaller footprints I think a
better I think we can say you know the
by footprint I mean you know the number
of exported things if you type io util
dot in most ideas you will get a list of
what's available to you and if that list
is like this you can just see it all in
one go then that's pretty good you know
we can see what's available in the
package we know what to do with it you
can't always do that sometimes the
packages are gonna grow you know but the
goal I think should be to drive towards
smaller footprints if we can just so
that it's easier and of course narrow
types are simpler so in this case I've
have this right Jason line and I'm
taking a file it's going to take an
object and write Marshall it is Jason
and save it in a file but this top one
can only write to a file whereas if we
change that and you know since the file
is an IO writer as well if we use our
writer instead suddenly we can write to
all kinds of different things that that
support I a writer it can still use the
file but now we can also do it to a
buffer and so we can not marshal stuff
in memory now we can do it to an HTTP
response writer that's a writer too and
therefore he works in servers now
and we can also use since the standard
library and other packages use these
these basic interfaces you can use those
too so we can now I can zip it easily so
it's things like that thinking about
narrow narrow types and sometimes
especially in this case actually you may
only have changed the signature you
probably depending on what your code is
doing you wouldn't even notice apart
from others have changed the variable
name but otherwise the code probably
inside it might just remain the same so
it's literally just a you know thinking
about it from that perspective and it's
worth seeking out single method
interfaces of your own as well
single method interfaces are they
they're so much better than even two two
methods is better than having three it's
simpler
but there's something special about just
one method in an interfacing go and your
code that you the packages that you
write and you know you probably can find
these yourself these these modeling
these concepts in this way and if it's
only got one method then it's easier to
implement and that's the point of an
interface we want people to implement
them right we want our users to
implement these interfaces and then of
course there's there's things you can do
if it's only a single method this
basically this slide is in every talk I
do I
I still love this I can't I can't go
over it I won't explain it because you
probably already know but google it if
you don't know or search from you know
different provider and lots of search
engines available just balance Bing Ask
Jeeves is that still a thing think
that's it
so yes basically we can have function
adaptors for single method interfaces
you can't do that if there's two methods
it doesn't make any sense so then
instead of a type you just have a
function so simpler and more versatile
and you can kind of do quirky stuff like
this this is real code this is a status
handler and it's a type that just is
based off int and implements the serve
HTTP method so it's an
itself is an HTTP handler so you can use
it you can map it in your routes and
things and this just just responds to a
request with a an HTTP status code so
then you can do it not found' handle it
just by casting an INT to that type you
know things like that and this is just
HTTP handlers as an example if you if
you've discovered your own single method
interfaces in your own contexts users
can do things like this and you can you
know with with kind of little little or
no effort which is awesome so structure
structuring packages as well structuring
the code properly and what do we really
mean by that well I think when when it
comes to deciding if you're gonna use a
package what I do is generally I'll scan
the list of files first and if there's
one file then I get the sense this is a
kind of small package it could still be
massive because this is nothing stopping
you having loads of stuff in that file
but we try try not to do that we try and
break things up and and group them a
little bit better there's a quote there
from David and unders I always like to
pronounce his name as if it's one word
for some reason David and unders it
seems to be better than perhaps you'd
like to consider changing it so he said
the first place I went to his voice it'd
be racist they said the first place I
look when considering using a package
are test files and this is kind of cool
right if you have a package and it's
open source and you want people to use
it they're gonna look at that and see
well is you know what's really the
quality of this yeah how good is this
package and if it doesn't have any tests
you sort of even if it's simple and
you've tested it yourself and you know
it works and it's brilliant still you
want you want to give people confidence
you want to you know they don't want to
be worrying about this this little thing
that they're using and so subfolders in
the project as well and we might as well
be similar to things that are emerging
because this is simpler and familiar and
it's kind of important and worth going
for so commands go into CMD packages
test data you know don't don't have a
folder
called some like I don't know a
different name for test data right it
seems now test data that's the name
where we that's where we put our test
data so let's just do that it's fine it
works great and so you never know
sometimes these patterns and things
might even become official a bit like
you know the vendor package and of like
internal as a folder you know it really
explains what the code is just just by
glancing at it there's a link here for a
great article actually goes into these
dracool I'll just pronounce the name and
there's a couple of things so use
multiple go files you know let's break
it by responsibility if you've got a
user type pop it pop it into users go
file at the top and then user related
things underneath it start with most
relevant at the top and go down to least
relevant that just as a general rule
make sense because if you think about
going to a new project and you think
okay I need to I want to know what this
user type is I need to figure just
figure something out
where you gonna look probably users go
file so in there that's where you should
be you know there's no reason to get
kind of creative at that level we might
as well go for being similar another
thing I would say for package writers is
to leave concurrency to the user we
naturally want to make the packages
useful and as awesome as possible and we
want to do concurrency because it's fun
and calling go but it's not always
obvious that what's happening and being
obvious is is pretty vital I think so so
here's this function do amazing thing
inside that it's going to go off and do
the amazing thing and that might make
perfect sense now we might want to
document that to say you know oh this is
going to run background tasks or maybe
we change the name so it's start so it's
clear that it's starting something but
actually you take away something from
the user which is the option to use it
as a blocking function which they may
want to do if if you
they can always do this themselves right
they can always manage the concurrency
on their end and they'll know it's going
to happen rather than it being magic and
inside the package and then like I said
they can use it in a blocking way to say
have then they have both options so if
unless you've got a great reason for
doing it which is most of these in fact
all any time there's a rule there's
always a great reason why you would
break that rule so absolutely that
doesn't still apply but I'm just talking
kind of generally right let's leave
concurrency is please leave concurrency
to the user
hopefully you're the first user of the
package this speaks a little bit to
building something that you need rather
than trying to kind of guess and and
just do something because you want to
aux it's fun but but if you are the
first user real user it's going to be a
better package and there's some things
you can do to help come at home one of
them is test-driven development I don't
think there's a more boring task than
writing unit tests for code that already
exists I can't be bothered to do that
for some reason I can't I'm not I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it right but when
I'm writing those tests like as at the
same time that I'm writing the package
when I'm doing it TDD style I very happy
to write those tests so that's that
might be a personal thing for me but I
know for sure that you know test-driven
development it drives up the code
coverage that you get and also helps you
think about since since you're writing a
test you sort of start to use the
package before it really exists so
you're already thinking ah so how would
I want how would I expect this to be
used or what would be the simplest way
to do this and you get to have that kind
of conversation you also know you're
aware of the API footprint from the very
beginning which is very important to
follow conventions and you know be
similar let's be similar to each other
in encode
yeah encode don't everyone like recede
your hairline I'm not saying you have to
be similar to me in that way
but don't think we can get it this after
right that's still a thing we can do if
so put some more hair in for me okay
don't talk about hair rule one in it
broke a know don't surprise people
either you know it's we do want to be
creative and and show off that we're
smart and cool don't make it boring make
it obvious because actually you can be
creative in different ways than actually
end up mattering a lot more so be
obvious not clever some write some jokes
now guys you ready this one I actually
did write the three hardest things
encoding our naming things in validating
the cache and in validating the cache no
that's what I thought
dead silence for anyone at home watching
this on YouTube later the audience isn't
miked up so if it's deadly silent after
I do a joke that's just because you know
you can't hear it but they'll absolutely
love in it brilliant we can put sound
into another one three hardest things
encoding are naming things off by one
errors yeah pathetic not doing it I'm
not I'm not doing jokes again not worth
it it's embarrassing but in both of
these jokes you will notice but they're
harder you know number one both of these
cases is naming things and that is kind
of key so let's think about again from a
user's point of view remember that the
package name is part of the API here's
an example we have a bruty function you
know this is how we write code like this
inside the package it makes sense we're
gonna brew some tea
we're gonna take a steep time and return
an error yep
cuz you can you can burn yourself or
have enough hot water
I don't know so but from the outside we
to use that you say tea brew tea and so
we get the bit of redundancy it's in
enough to say tea brew and so again
think about from the users perspective
TDOT Brook makes perfect sense and it's
much nicer I think so
export um I mean then by exposed
yourself to the API footprint from the
beginning this is really TDD helps to do
this you know when you press dot and see
that little list that's really I think
sometimes it that's all the
documentation you need for good packages
you only need to see that and it's quite
obvious what you're gonna do some cases
are more difficult and you need you know
more there's a lot more types or the
concepts are harder to model whatever so
totally fine but there's things we can
do to help in this way too which is one
of them is to put test code in a
different package so in the same folder
still but use the underscore test
package name and what that does is it
means that you have to in order to call
the methods and use the types from your
package you have to use the package name
and you have to import it so you get to
see how people are gonna use this again
you get to see that directly as you're
kind of writing it and you can use go
doc early too if you do go doc HTTP 8080
or whatever it will on localhost 8080
will give you the go doc thing but with
loads of extra packages basically
everything you've you've go get it could
be that but also the package you're
working on and you can see that too and
kind of refresh it and and get a sense
of that footprint as well for your
package because that's really what
remember that's the first thing people
are gonna see probably when they if
they're considering using your code and
this isn't all about open source this
all this all this stuff applies to your
own internal packages as well you know
having you your future self is also
gonna use the package as well as your
teammates and things like this so it all
applies still but it's especially true I
think with with open source
don't log stuff out of a package it's
annoying
Oh make it make it a dependency or
something you can control to turn it off
for debugging and maybe even for your
own case you definitely want those log
statements there but but not everyone
does or they might do logging
differently or you know and you sort of
take away that control by by just
logging things directly so avoid that I
would say make zero values useful this
applies everywhere but it's quite nice
so I have this greeter type here and you
can see the greet method checks to see
if the format's empty and if it is used
as a default format and that means we
can we can use the types just by you
know declaring it and get on and use it
so we say hi to Dean by just creating a
greeter without having to actually do
anything but then that also we can we
can control it you know so zip you know
think about that too
what's the what's the behavior of this
by default this extends to even if if
your code is going to connect to say nsq
then then nsq has default ports and
things that it will listen to so just
you have them as the default right it
makes sense so you can just start nsq
run the thing and it sort of works
without having you having to do those
extra cognitive steps if you can avoid
constructors do and the reason for that
is if you look at this we have this
we're creating a brewer here to brew
some more tea and bert in the top
example we don't know what's happening
we can't really be sure but what's being
allocated is it kicking off go routines
we'd have to go and look at the code if
we if we want to find out about that
versus the second one which basically
it's a bit more typing so you know
generally we'll think we want to be
willing to help our users by not making
them type too much so we'll do the top
one but the second one is actually a lot
clearer look you know that you're
creating a brewer that's what you're
allocating you set in this deep time
before you sort of had you'd have to
know the argument name to see what that
what
two minutes means and you know that no
go routines is starting it's not doing
anything else
magic you've got it there so if you can
do that I think that's a good practice
to do plus you shrink the API footprint
because you then don't need the extra
function to create the thing now again
sometimes you know you've got ten
channels you've got a create and some
maps and stuff and it would be a pain to
expect users to do that then call do a
constructor avoid it if you can I would
say don't automatically add interfaces
yeah this you know again we think we're
gonna we want this interface we've found
maybe it's a single method interface and
we love it or maybe it's just something
that we want other people to implement
you know as as this it grows this and
grows in success in popularity this
package but we don't need to add that
interface necessarily so don't
automatically do it here's an example we
have their greeter again and we have a
format greeter what we kind of don't
really need both of those and it's not
gonna be obvious when someone starts to
use this what which one they use you
know they could easily try and create a
discreet to type and things so so it's
about shrinking the API footprint if you
do want to keep the interface you could
actually not expose the other one don't
expose the structure the actual
implementation but have a function that
creates that and you can kind of keep
your types internally and this is nice
because then you have a greeter
interface only there's a function that
returns a greeter but it happens to do
you know it happens to be greet using a
format we could have other types or the
people could add them later so yes use
go like names this is a thing I have
seen code where somebody's done a port
from say Java or Ruby and you end up
with very big method names and it's you
know it's kind of really telling you
exactly everything
it's going on go doesn't really have
that style it tends we tend to prefer
smaller and more succinct examples one
example I saw online was like Marshall
with indentation could be just you know
and is Marshall indent you know simple
tells you enough without properly you
know x over explaining and similarly
like tear down you might be doing
something that's going to tear something
down but maybe maybe we just use clothes
because clothes as a concept we have
there's even an interface closer so you
know maybe that makes sense
ask the user for HTTP client if you are
making HTTP requests let the user
provide the client they can control it
and in some cases if you didn't do this
like on App Engine you can't make
requests using the default client on App
Engine you have to ask for a new client
from the URL fetch package so you
actually prevent your code from being
able to run in App Engine just because
you know you're kind of making that
decision about the HTTP client by all
means you know make the zero make the
default useful so default to the default
client if you like but let the user give
you their client context probably should
be the first argument if you're gonna
have context have is the first argument
I did see an example somewhere where
there were a few arguments and context
was just one of them and it kind of just
felt weird so I put this slide in there
yes don't mess with the global state
please so don't add flags even though
that might make perfect sense and you
might think well in every case when
someone's going to use my package it's
gonna be in a command and these are
flags that are standard and all that
there's probably some great reasons why
you'd want to do it but I think it's
better to avoid it because it sort of
just pollutes things and it has some
surprising side effects similarly if you
can avoid in it as well you know it can
be it can definitely be misused in it
and really it's it's just not clear to
the to somebody what's going to have
and really being clarity and being
obvious and things of sort of the the
goal and don't mess with anything in the
standard library for example there was a
something which set a timeout in the
default client it added a timeout so it
changed the default client or something
like this it did something you know
which made sense in that in the wrong
context but just by importing a package
suddenly you've changed something and
you're gonna have kind of strange side
effects potentially so avoid side
effects and magic and be obvious and
clear sub packages are just packages
we'd advise and originally we had this
test package it's an interface test so
it's basically a function that you call
in test code and it tests against the
interface but it tests an implementation
so you know if if you want to write an
implementation for vice as long as these
tests pass then it's okay it's good it
can go in which is a cool little thing
if you if you are exposing an interface
and you want you want people to write
implementations that's a nice way to
help them do that but we had if you look
at the import path its Vice slash test
so in that context it's very clear what
that is but in the code
suddenly it's just the package name is
just test so you're saying test
transport and it's like not sure what
that is anymore so we changed it to vice
test so there's a bit of redundancy now
in the import path which is part of the
user experience so we you know we want
that to be nice and succinct and simple
there's a little bit there but it's
probably worth it because now in the
function bodies we say vice test dot
transport both clear and and very
obvious come up with a good name for
your packages and you can be a bit
creative here but also make sure it's
kind of clear what it is
vice isn't a great example of this but
you know coming up with names that are
gonna be easy quick to type and because
you know package name remember it's
gonna they're gonna use that throughout
the code so these names should be nice
and short and
to the point and not every go project
needs to mention go if it's a client
like AWS client for go
that makes sense go AWS cool otherwise I
don't think we need to to do it but and
even in that case if you import a
package called AWS you know it's in go
that's sort of enough I think for you to
remember that this is a go project give
your project a logo or a mascot I can't
stress how surprising the response to
your code I forgot how I started that
sentence so icon I can't express how I
can't express Halon was very surprised
bald man can't be fooled twice don't
listen to that statistic I made it it's
falling apart in it guys no it's not
it's going well don't look at me like
that going well okay sorry yeah
I'm not kidding though right a project
with a logo just gets is I don't know
why some emotional buy-in or something
and and it's just a great way to have
some fun I'm again I'm going to prove
this to you now we're gonna play a
little game that I like to call name
that project so I want you to shout out
so this is audience participation and
people at home on YouTube I don't care
where you are shout it out please I'm
going to show you a logo and you tell me
what the project is and this the point
of this is to show you that the the logo
helps remember a project so we'll start
with an easy one what about this one mmm
buffalo is it buffalo or go buffalo oh
okay
good point well oh yeah okay this one
might be a bit tough yes it's a gorilla
what's the project gorilla toolkit
correct yeah we probably everyone in
this room's use this actually in and
this Biffen and you know it's an it's
not very prominent logo
so it sort of speaks to my point which
is you know you well I don't know forget
it this one yeah anyone at the back want
to join in no that's fine
yep that's Travis this one's one of my
favorites
correct what about that got some got
some programmers in okay
might be a bit tough anyone know this
hmm nsq yeah no yeah all right tough one
Hugo at the the t-shirt the what the
logo on the t-shirt
not the not their gopher not the Gopher
eyes me little the little t-shirt what's
that
come on guys join in it's not fun if you
just yes get hurt brilliant cool um okay
that was good one it really good that
bit okay computers can help to computers
there are tools which will help you know
you can ruin go lint go vet there's a
metal inter which kind of runs all of
them and you can you can have this
running every time you save and every
time you run your tests and things so
that you see quite early you start
seeing things like oh this this exported
thing should be should have a comment
you know and if you if you don't do the
comments in in the kind of standard way
it'll prompt you to that as well then
it'll say yeah you know we we start the
comment with the method name generally
so do that and there's also go report
card which is quite cool and this this
is essentially a service that runs
essentially the the metal inter gives
you a a breakdown and a score and you
can see here that the
there's some lint problems in in Vice
when I run it so I only got 93% of that
but otherwise very good and this this
kind of helps it's it seems maybe it's
kind of game with buying a little bit
but the value in this is you if if this
is high scoring project it means that
the the person it's going to be familiar
to you first of all comma it's going to
be well-documented there aren't going to
be strangeness there aren't going to be
strange things like underscores in in
names and stuff like that you know it'll
catch it catch that kind of that kind of
stuff
and if we want to be self similar and
build a code base that we can pick up
and and use easily then then this is
this is these are all valuable things so
how do you spot a quality package then
do they did they use a go front if if
not then that's imagine seeing go code
that's not formatted now that would be
very strange and you probably wouldn't
have much confidence in it rightly or
wrongly it may be a brilliant package
but that's a thing to test to consider
when you look at it test files does it
are there any test files if not not
going to be happy probably not very
confident that this thing's going to do
what we expect it to do yeah they're
using Java names big big long
descriptions or Ruby we're in Ruby you
can just write a any method you want you
just write it like as a sentence with
underscores and it works which is
amazing but it didn't really it's not
really a go thing we don't have
you know catch-all methods and things
like that and finally how many
dependencies does it have and the fewer
the better probably because you know
there's less baggage coming along with
that with that package you know if it
just has the standard library it it's
you probably going to use it with a bit
more confidence especially as we're
still figuring out dependency management
and things like that you sort of avoid
the problem if there's no dependencies
obviously not always possible again but
is better I've said less is better
that's that's not even correct English
that's embarrassing fewer is better
sounds worse than it by thank you
[Applause]